- So Sadie, are you going
to get to spend the holidays
with your family or are
you going back home,
or where do you go?
- Yeah, I'm gonna, I'm
gonna be with my family,
and we have, I mean, some very
exciting holiday traditions.
- [Kelly] Wait, what are they?
- (sighs) I mean, Christmas
Eve karaoke is big.
- Yes.
- And then also, we do
like a cookie decorating competition,
and it's gets very competitive.
- I love your family.
- [Sadie] Yeah.
(audience chuckles)
- Now does this end poorly sometimes?
- Oh yeah.
- Okay. (laughs)
- A few tears have been shed
in the past years.
(Kelly chuckles)
- My family is competitive too.
My favorite part is my mother's like,
"You and your sister,
y'all are so competitive,"
and we're like, "You're like
the queen of competitive."
(Sadie and audience chuckle)
She's like, she throws
shade better than anyone,
and like, you don't even
know what's happening.
Are you competitive?
Do you play games with
your family, Brendan?
- Full contact karaoke.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
♪ Should I stay or should I go now? ♪
(Kelly, Sadie and audience all laugh)
- Okay. You just upped karaoke in general.
I love your version.
Well, to both of you,
do you remember the coolest
gift you ever received?
Like when you were little?
- Probably an American girl doll.
I mean, they were huge
- Oh my God, you're so young.
(Kelly chuckles)
- Very special.
- Those weren't even around
when I was a kid.
(both laugh)
That's amazing.
Do you remember which one?
My daughter loves the American girl.
- Oh, Kit. Kit Ridge
- Oh, Kit, yes.
Love it.
All right, all right.
What about you, Brendan?
When you were little, what was
one of your favorite gifts?
- Only doll I got was a GI Joe.
♪ GI Joe. ♪
I remember those.
Yeah.
- It came with a parachute
built into his back.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And I threw him off the
balcony from the second floor,
and he got stuck in a tree
until the next spring.
He just kind of hung there.
(audience groans and laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that story, still
He's still America's greatest hero.